hi my name is ruth and i'm a foley
artist
[Music]
we basically record all the sounds that
actors make in the studio
after the film has been made and it
could be anything from footsteps to
making a cup of tea to having a fight to
a car crash anything you like we can
pretty much do it
so this is a slinky
on its own just a child's toy but if you
add the box
you can make something that sounds
really
quite special
the sound is coming through the box the
box is acting like a resonance chamber
and that's what
makes the noise and you might recognize
the sound as the lasers from star wars
this is a pile of videotape
the wonderful thing about this i think
is that it's very synthetic as a
material but it really sounds like the
leaves in trees
and we can also do the sound of people
walking through very thick layers of
leaves
it might just be a layer on top of the
normal footsteps that we would do
this is a snow bag
it's quite difficult to record the sound
of people walking through thick snow in
the studio as you might imagine
snow melts quite quickly so we have here
just a
material bag filled with corn flour
and you can hear it gives that wonderful
creak that snow footsteps make
[Applause]
this is what i call a sea sausage there
are only two in existence and i know
that because i made them
and yet somehow even though it's just a
piece of material and some gravel it
really sounds like the sea it sounds
like waves on a pebbly beach
it's quite
meditative you could do it for hours
so this would be
rain on
a tin roof
and you can get some
individual raindrops as well
this is a thunder tube made by my friend
paul
you can see it's just made out of some
piping
with some
plastic
taped over it and a spring attached
these are my coconuts
people often ask when they find out that
i'm a foley artist if we still use
coconuts for horses and the answer is
well yes we do but we don't do them like
this
which is
how monty python did it
they kind of ruined it for us we would
normally use them on the ground to make
the sound of the horses on whatever
surface they're on whether it's concrete
or
a dirt road or grass or something
these are three items that might not do
very much on their own but if you put
them together
get the sound
of a machine gun
being
held by a
soldier as they run along i think that's
one of the the joys of doing foley
actually is that we use these homemade
items often to create some really
beautiful sound effects
so here are a collection of different
gloves
these i would use for bird
wings
[Applause]
these are little bird call instruments
essentially they're just uh pieces of
metal that are rubbing with the on the
wood
that encloses it
little percussion instruments
most nature documentaries have full
cover foley all cameras can zoom in
really closely now the technology is
incredible obviously you've seen some of
the recent programs when they can get
into the beaks and the feathers of the
birds and things but you can't do that
with microphones in the same way so they
really have to use foley it's really
essential for nature documentaries to
make it sound real something fake to
make it sound real that's the the lovely
paradox
celery
very useful when it comes to fight
scenes makes the sounds of various
bones being broken or nose is being
punched and things we get a bit violent
with the vegetables in the studio
sometimes when it comes to zombie films
for example it's really useful to have
some celery a melon and a cabbage at
hand because you will have to
make all those gory sounds from scratch
imagine them pulling the
rib cage open and things like that also
when it comes to doing uh operations or
in something like silent witness when
they're cutting open dead bodies we also
use a lot of celery
by the way great name for the memoir
violence with the vegetables
oh thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so the stunt coordinator was going to
fire the air ramp so it had a lead with
the button going to him offset when he
does fire the button i'm virtually in
line with the ground so he fires the air
ram which fires me straight onto the
back of my neck and literally i'm lying
on the floor and i can't feel my legs
and this went on for about two minutes
it's the worst feeling in the world you
know i thought it was paralyzed could
not feel my legs at all sort of broken
my neck